so the course I teach is a first-year
seminar called history of sexuality and
the approach that I take is I look at
the ways that scientists and physicians
over the past hundred years have tried
to study human sexuality so we go back
and we start with Richard from craft a
being who in the 1880s used examples
from his own psychiatric practice of
patients who are struggling with gender
identity or sexual orientation and I
should caution you that those are words
that we use to describe what he's
describing he used obviously a very
different set of words and part of our
interest is what is he interested in how
does he describe them he's very vivid in
describing the lives and experiences of
his patients and I think it's really
eye-opening because most of us naively
think that victorian-era
oh they didn't talk about sex oh they
didn't really do anything very out of
the normal sexually they were all sort
of married and having sex within
marriage but when you read his
descriptions of his patients you find
out that's very much not true and that
there was also a very self-conscious
understanding of what was going on both
on the part of the people engaged in
these activities and also emerging on
the part of the psychiatrists working on
this and then we keep moving forward we
look in the 1920s when anthropology
becomes really big in this field at
Malinowski's book called the sexual life
of savages where he goes to the
Trobriand islands and tries to
understand what is the sexual life of
this group of people living there and
basically what he finds as he finds that
they're much freer and easier with
sexuality that children are engaged in
sexual games that monogamy is not held
in as high esteem as it is in Europe in
around 1900 and he's very interested in
the freedom and the lack of difficulties
that this culture seems to offer in
comparison with his experience of
European culture we also then jump up to
Alfred Kinsey many of you may have heard
of the kinsey reports about five years
ago there was a Hollywood movie looking
at the production of the kinsey reports
and what Kinsey tried to do is do
very wide-ranging study of tens of
thousands of Americans in the 1940s
1950s about their sexual behaviors and a
number of the things that he found were
extremely shocking when he published
them but are sort of things we take for
granted now things like that most people
have sex before they get married at a
time when it was thought that no one had
sex before they got married that people
have same-sex relationships that women
have affairs while they're married which
no one thought was the case and we look
at his methods we read some of his texts
we also look at a slightly earlier
example of the study of women's
sexuality looking at the experience of
women who went to women's colleges in
1920s and whether or not they were still
happy if they married men so a lot of
these things are framed in the time
we're trying to understand the study of
human sexuality at the time it happens
so then when we get to the current
discussions of human sexuality I try to
encourage the students not to just say
oh now we have it right everybody who
worked on this in the past hundred years
weren't very good thinkers but now we
have it right the idea is that all of
our scientific studies of any subject
but particularly of sexuality are really
imbued with our cultural and social
notions so I want to give first-year
students no matter what kind of high
school they went to a really good
background and really good tools so
they're able to take on really
independent projects while they are at
Yale one of the first things we try to
take on is what happens when you're
assigned a really hard text to read and
we read two kinds of hard texts one is
these old scientific texts I mean for
those of you who aren't doing science a
contemporary scientific text is pretty
hard but then couple it with really old
ideas and really old fashioned language
and they get really hard so how to read
these old texts and define something
useful in things that your first
reaction is well they're wrong the
question then becomes interesting well
why did the major thinkers of that time
think this if it's so obviously wrong
and you get into a very nice discussion
the second kind of hard texts we read
are what is known as theory that is
people who
look at these primary texts if you will
and try to create a more overarching
understanding of say human sexuality so
the two theorists we read are Michele
Foucault and Freud and they're hard
because they make these very grand
statements and again have their own kind
of vocabulary and set of issues and in
both cases we spend several class
sessions on the readings to try to learn
how to really understand what they're
getting at so to go online with that we
write three different papers the first
paper is looking at a primary source
that is one of these physicians or
scientists writing about sexuality and
they have to pick two of them and
compare them on a set of issues that I
offer so how do you create a paper
that's based on close reading and
citation of a pretty hard primary text
that's the first paper the second paper
is how do you write about theory how do
you write about really smart people
writing about theoretical ideas and some
first-year students are really
intimidated by the idea of writing
comparing fucose ideas and Freud's ideas
when they maybe only understand them
partially and so we talk about how
that's kind of a standard of life that
maybe the portion of what you understand
these texts grows as you get further in
your education but it's always a good
idea to be somewhat humble in the face
of them and say I only understand part
of them and one thing I encourage
students to do is imagine you're
actually at a dinner party with these
two illustrious men and your goal as the
host or hostess is to try to keep the
dinner party conversation going without
having anybody come to blows so you ask
tossed questions out there that both
people will be interested in answering
but you want to keep the discussion
going and that's really your role as the
writer of a paper you want to keep the
discussion going between the two authors
you're trying to compare and then
finally the part of the class that many
students find to be their favorite is
they do a small original research paper
Yale is really lucky and that has a
tremendous archive on the subject of
sexuality actually we have several
different archives but the one we use is
the one in manuscripts and archives and
it's hard because the kinds of documents
that people have left in the past very
often were silent on the issue of
sexuality
but archivists and other scholars have
really gone through with a fine-tooth
comb and picked out for example letters
and large families letter collections
that refer obliquely to sexual behaviors
or sexual relationships or romantic
relationships and these are all flagged
already for us so we spend three weeks
in the archives actually really getting
students comfortable with working with
archival materials they frame their own
questions they pick their own objects
and they write a short research paper
and many of the students tell me that
that gives them the confidence after
that to sign up for classes that say
they have a research paper at the end as
many of our classes do and just to
conclude one of the things that many
students come into the course with is
they say they're taking the class
because they want to know whether
homosexuality is biological or cultural
and I smile and say I want to know that
too but the route I said ah you're not
at the end of the class gonna know the
answer to that because as far as I can
I'm concerned no one knows the answer to
that what you're gonna know is why that
question is so interesting to us and
when did that question become
interesting and why is it very
interesting to us now and many of the
students at the end of the class say
yeah I don't really want to know the
answer to that anymore but it's I really
realized what an interesting question it
is how much deeper of a question it is
than they thought when they started the
Freshman Seminar program at Yale is a
really awesome one because many
first-year students don't have the
opportunity to take a small
discussion-based course and if they do
manage to get into one they're the only
first-year student in a course of
juniors and seniors and it's pretty
scary frankly so the first year some of
our program offers the opportunity to be
in a seminar class of all other
first-year students taught by a faculty
member so there's a process for getting
into this there's a lottery that you
sign up for so you know I had last time
I thought this 144 students sign up for
my 18 spots and it was done by lottery
so I'm pretty sure there's not a real
way of saying who chose the class from
that means what it ends up with though
is a real genuine diversity of
backgrounds and when I go around and ask
students why they're taking it the main
reason that they give me is that
sexuality was something that wasn't
talked about in their families it wasn't
talked about in their churches and it
sure wasn't talked about in their
schools and
in fact they've never talked about it
and they're really wondering how you can
talk about it in a scholarly way in a
classroom setting and they just are
curious about anything I have to offer
so one of the benefits of the class too
is that people feel comfortable talking
about fairly frank sexual subjects not
about their own personal experiences but
about the cultures experience about the
ways that we represent other individuals
experiences the way that we understand
human sexuality as a concept so it's
really diverse in terms of background
one of the really interesting
backgrounds that people bring to my
class are when they come from other
countries in the world and I know I had
one student from Pakistan who took my
class and at the end was so excited he
said you know they don't study this at
universities in my country I'm going to
go back to Pakistan and found a
sexuality studies Department I'm like
yeah you go so there's a lot of
different perspectives and we heard a
lot from one student about the wisdom of
her Kenyan grandmother about human
sexuality and the advice that she gave
her so it's a it's great to have all the
different backgrounds in that class so I
also have a role I'm half of my position
at Yale I direct the office of LGBTQ
resources so I work in creating a
supportive environment for students
staff and faculty who may identify as
lesbian gay bisexual transgender or
queer on this campus so it's really nice
for me to also be in this classroom
setting where people may not have strong
identifications with those letters in
the alphabet or may or they may be
emerging and just having the opportunity
to talk about the history of where those
words came from the times that they were
used more by medical professionals to
label people the times that they were
more embraced by individuals with those
identities so I find also that the
students who are in my first-year
seminars I keep in touch with I always
run into them later on so many of them
become freshman counselors for example
partly because I think they've learned
how to be comfortable talking about some
difficult things maybe they already wear
somewhat comfortable talking about those
things they were they wouldn't have even
taken the class this year I was also
direct
undergraduate studies for WGS s and of
our seniors five of those seniors took
my first year seminar when they were
first year so it's been really wonderful
to see how they've grown and developed
and they come and tell me every time
they read Fuko sadly they don't read
Freud again mostly but they read
Foucault again and they'll come and talk
to me and say oh this time when I read
Foucault I really saw that point you
were making but I didn't get at all when
I was a first-year and it's just such a
pleasure to watch them grow and develop
and also to watch their comfort with the
archives
I think after they've done that archival
project so many of them go on and do to
archival projects for courses and for
their senior essays so it's just a
pleasure to to keep in touch with them
and watch them continue to grow and
change as they spend their four years at
you